The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare@ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: First the
midterm number two--
if you look at the syllabus,
we have two midterms arranged/.
The first one is in class.
The second one is taken home.
And now you can see
why it's taken home.
Its problems with take time.
But the thing about
taking home, I always
thought of my own experience.
If I give you on Friday, you'll
spend your whole weekend on it.
So what I am doing is
giving it on Monday
at the end of the lecture.
And then we'll come in
Wednesday at the beginning
of the lecture.
So it's a short pen, hopefully.
Any question?
If you ask what
are the problems,
I posted the examples.
So my challenge is to make the
problem in the next few days
that's solvable.
And there are no problem
I can go-- every time,
I have to think hard
of what other problem
I can make that's a reasonable.
So any questions there?
Or maybe you have a
suggestion for problem.
So let's review what we've
been talking in the last two
lectures.
We were solving the
Boltzmann question
looking at the classic
or size effects
when the heat carriers say,
collide with the boundary.
So we took the simplest
configuration, a thin film
that has two surfaces.
And two lectures
ago, we discussed
when you have a heat
flow along the film plan,
where of course, the heat
carrier not just a parallel
flow.
Say the random velocity
can go hit the boundary.
At the boundary, they
diffuse, scatter.
Or the partially diffuse
and partially scatter.
And the second the
problem that we
dealt with in the
last lecture is let's
now have the heat transfer in
the perpendicular direction.
When I say heat, I
hope now you agree,
it's to say I can do charge.
I can do say, photon.
I can do say, molecule.
And in fact that the
molecular heat conduction
is a more difficult
problem, believe it or not,
that's because if I
do the gas molecule,
I have also a
concentration gradient.
So even the same material,
the higher temperature,
if you think about ideal
gas law, and the density
will change.
So when density change, you
also have a mass diffusion.
In other words, in
the same material,
there is a mass diffusion.
That's an integral equation.
So you actually have to solve
two integral equations together
for the molecular case.
For fallout, let's just say
it's not considered the density
variations.
So it's one integral equation.
And the difference
is in this case,
the temperature is
inside the integral.
So even we use the relaxation
time approximation,
the Boltzmann equation
itself, is the first order
differentiable
equation by the end
because transport
is a long local.
When I say long local, I mean,
the heat flow at any point
is not just a local gradient.
It depends on the temperature
history directly integration
through the whole domain.
So that's the
non-local transport.
And then we have to solve
the integral equation.
And the rarefied gas flow,
we didn't solve this problem.
But I discussed if
you go to solve,
you start off
combination of the two.
Because I have flow
in the x-direction,
I have a source term that's
a function of x But also, I
have the boundary that
constrain the molecules
and the boundaries scatter.
So if we solve this, I
discussed the [? Lucien ?]
minimum phenomena.
And the velocity
distribution now has a slip.
So there is a discontinuity
of the molecules, either wall.
And I want to say that
this discontinuity--
so normally if you
say, in 2005, what
were undergraduate fluid
mechanics heat transfer,
we always say at the wall,
the temperature is continuous.
The velocity equals
the wall velocity.
That's the long-sleeve boundary
condition for both temperature
and for velocity.
And the reality is
there is always slip.
That slip happens over 1
molecular mean free path.
So now let's think
about the air molecule
free path, 100 nanometer.
And if I have slip
over 100 nanometer,
but if I deal with
the meter scale,
so that slip is too small
to be actually observable
or of any significance.
So this is always happening
except for in the case
of liquid.
I will move on to
the liquid version.
So that's what we deal
with, more or less,
in the rigorous in terms
of solving the Boltzmann
equation on the relaxation
time approximation.
And of course, the
difficulty is now
even for this simplest
problem like heat conduction,
you realize that we have to
go solve an integral equation,
which is by no means, trivial.
So what I'm going to introduce
relaxed some approximate ways,
just attribute all the
effects to the boundary,
to the interface.
So we'll use diffusion
approximation,
using for real or in
the inside the domain.
But at the boundary, I gave
a slip boundary condition.
So how I should derive that
slip boundary condition?
And I want to actually
say I want to show you
a few papers I wrote on this.
And it turns out every field has
this slip boundary condition.
In the radiation, there's the
so-called [? Dessler ?] jump,
boundary condition.
And in fluid mechanics,
there's a first order slip,
second order slip.
And in heat
conduction, I mentioned
there's a temperature
jump when we solve
say, the perpendicular flow.
And in electrical field, there
is also interfacial resistance,
electrical resistance.
So this is all related
to what is this slip.
I'll make more comments when
we go to look at these papers.
But the diffusion approximation
plus boundary slip--
so what I'm saying
is the diffusion
approximation, of
course, is what
we've been talking chapter 6.
That's how we derive Fourier
law, Ohm's law, and all
these continuum equations.
And what I want is to use
this diffusion approximation.
So the way I derive their part
diffusion is the distribution
function, f equals f0
minus tau vx, df0 dx.
So I'm not writing
the fourth term.
For electron, you have
to write the fourth term.
So this is the one that I we
use to derive the Fourier law--
df0/dx df0 dt/dx.
So what I'm going
to do is the idea
is that I'm going to use this,
assume this small deviation
from equilibrium, and
this distribution function
apply to every domain,
right to the interface.
So here I have a boundary
between two material, 1 and 2.
And say the one side, I
have distribution function.
So f1 equals f0, 1 minus
tau 1 vx1 df0, 1/dx.
So this is on the first side.
On second side, you
can write the same--
f2 equal f0,2 tau vx2 df0, 2/dx.
So we're assuming that
it's valid to the boundary.
Of course, this is
an approximation.
I don't have a
good justification.
In fact, it's only
you can say OK,
maybe in the case
of [? Lucien ?]
number is not very large.
Then you can say
most of the region
is still diffusion-dominated.
But turns out this
will actually work out
pretty wide range of
[? Lucien ?] number
in many cases.
And then I'm going
to do the heat flux.
So if I do heat flux, I can
do particle flux, any flux.
But let me write the heat flux.
So the heat flux--
and if I think about
the inside diffusion,
just think about the physics,
this is an inside domain.
We say this is a deviation.
So what it means the transport
is in the same material.
What diffusion really
mean, the distribution
function f0 is isotropic,
so it's a sphere.
And then say I have
a small deviation.
And if my heat flow
is in this direction,
so I have in the forward,
I have a surplus.
I work backward because
the velocity is a negative
because I have a deficiency.
It's really, we emphasize is
this region that's the surplus.
And this deficiency,
this two parts that
contribute to the left flux.
F0 itself, when you
integrate, there
is equal amount of heat
going forward the backward.
There's no left flux
in this material.
But things will be different
when I go to the interface
because the f0 in
this first media.
And the f0, 2 in the two
media could be different.
So now I do the left flux.
So again, start with my
summation of all the modes.
In this case, what's left
flux across the interface
is all the ones that go forward
and that could transmit.
I'll have to multiply by the
transmittance from 1 to 2.
So I say OK, I do my typical
polarization kx, ky, kz.
This is a side one, so
everything I put into side one.
That's gain, I'm summing
my quantum states.
And the vx1, so this is a vx1.
Vx1 must be positive.
That's the going
from left to right.
So that means my kx1,
and that's the v vector,
must be larger than 0.
The wave is going
from left to right.
And h-bar omega, and I have f1.
And I have then say, tau 1 to 2,
the transmittance from 1 to 2.
For example, in
chapter 5, we know
how to tackle
transmittance, find
the formula for
if you do photons,
and similar electron-photons.
So this is the half
going from 1 to 2.
And then I come the
other half from 2 to 1.
The difference gives
me the left flux.
We always been
trying to do this.
So the other half is say
p2 on the second side.
And this is a kx2 less than 0.
So this is velocity
is less than 0.
So plus side is
really say ky2, kz2.
And the way x2, in
this case, is negative.
So the plus is really minus.
So it's the
difference of the two.
So h-bar omega, f2 tau 2 to 1.
So in a lot more
same material, I
do not write it into two parts.
In the same material, I
just write it into my f.
And I don't say this k, I sum
up or both positive and negative
k.
And in that case, the
f0, like I said, cancel.
This is the isotropic.
But in this case, if
I substitute the f1
into here and f2, I
didn't write into here.
And what I'll get is
the f0,1 and the f0, 2.
And because the property on
the two side are not the same,
you will not cancel each other.
And in fact, if you
go back to chapter 5,
you will also say
that in the chapter 5,
we talked about
the detail balance.
So what I'll have is
an f0, 1, if I just
think about this term, f0,
1 and modulated by tau 1, 2.
The rest is a v, h-bar
omega, that's the same.
And here is a v2 f0, 2, and
h-bar omega, tau 2 to 1.
So I have this transmissivity
from 1 to 2, and 2 to 1.
I say you always have
that detail balance you
can right into one side only.
That's what we did in Chapter 5.
So there's the intermediate step
mass, just too much writing,
so I'm not going to
explicitly put it there.
So what I want is
your understanding.
So that's the first
term, f0,1 term.
Now this tau vx1
df0/dx, this is the term
when I write in
the same material,
I will get the
thermal conductivity.
If I write in the same
material, I sum up.
And I have positive
side and negative side.
The two, it's
really, they add up.
This is not a consolation now,
because this is a deficiency.
This is the excess.
You go to look at your mass.
This 2 term actually,
because velocity is reversed,
is a summation.
So but in this case, I'm
doing half only, kx1,
so it's larger than 0.
So this is only this
part, the surplus part.
And when I do this term,
it's only this part.
So I actually have a 1/2 q
modulated by transmittance,
because normally in
the same material,
I do not have this
transmittance issue.
So if you follow what I
say, you put it in the mass,
you convert it
into the integral.
What do you have is--
so what I'll get is sum of--
I'm still writing sum, I haven't
converted into an integral.
Vx1 larger than 0--
you can still do
your polarization.
K also, or either write
it in k or in j, Ky1, kz1,
and h-bar omega and tau 1 to 2.
And vx1, f0, 1 minus f0, 2.
I'm using the detail balance.
The detail balance, if there
is no temperature difference,
the left to right equals
the right to left.
So there is a relation between
transmittance of the two sides.
So using that relation, I could
write this detail balance.
So this is the 0,
1 and 0, 2 term.
But I have this tau dx of the 0,
term as I said, is a 1/2 the q.
So if you do the math,
you say OK, from 1 to 2
is tau 1 to 2 prime q over 2.
And in fact, you
can write this q1.
This is the flux
on the first side,
but the half because I'm
only doing positive part.
And of course, I also
have this transmittance.
And now I put a prime because
when you do this vx squared,
vx1 squared, there's
sine squared.
So you integrate over angle.
So this transmittance
is integrated, weighted
transmittance, sine squared.
There's sine squared,
cosine, that's
when you convert into
spherical coordinate.
And similarly, I have tau,
2 to 1 prime, q to q2 to 1.
That's on the other side.
This is the diffusion.
Again, if you write
the Fourier law,
you will be matched 1, dt/dx.
That's your q.
If it's same material,
that's what you would do.
So what I'm showing is
now at the interface,
because of the asymmetry
of the 0th order term
on the two sides, I don't
have cancellation anymore.
And this is 0th order
term, so when I have q,
I can put this 2q on the
other side, combined.
So I will combine this.
so q1, q2-- if there's no
interface heat generation.
If there is interface
heat generation,
I have to be careful.
If there's no interface
generation, this q1,
q2 should equal to each other
because of the continuity
of the heat flow.
So all this is q1
equals q2 equals q
under no heat generation.
So I plug in, I have 1 minus
1/2 tau 1,2-prime plus 2,
1-prime q equals--
now f0, 1 and f0,2,
0, 1, let's say,
is related to temperature
on the T1 on the first side
at the interface.
So I have this one is T1.
And this is a T2,
the temperature.
So if the difference is
not large, what I can write
is into, so this is
I write a delta T
and with x1 larger than 0.
And we say ky1, kz1.
And again, you sum up with the
polarization and tau 1 to 2
and the v1 h-bar
omega, df0, 1/dt.
So I'm writing
basically f0, 1, f0, 2.
Really what it means is
f0,1 T1, this is an f0 T2.
Because if you think about
Bose-Einstein distribution,
it doesn't have anything other
h-bar omega divided by kt.
So yourself is just to say,
write into differential times
this times your difference
across the interface.
So actually, you see
this derivation show me
I have a interfacial
temperature drop because
of the asymmetry of my
distribution on the two sides.
And the 0th order
term doesn't cancel.
And of course, this one you can
again, convert your summation
into integration.
And this conversion, there
is a slight difference.
This is a tau 1,2.
Here, I have vx1.
Here when I do q, I have vx1.
But I also f1 have
another tau vx1.
So that's vx1 squared in 2q.
Vx1 squared has
sine theta squared.
Vx1 just a sine theta.
So my average in for
this transmittance
is actually slight
different the average
and weighted in terms
of angle weighted.
So if you do this,
what you have is
you can rather into integral.
This is 0 omega max and h-bar
omega df0, 1/dt, and density
of states on the one side.
And then what you have on
this side is 1/2 0 to 1 tau 1
to 2 mu/d mu.
So this is what
comes from this sine.
Vx1 has a sine theta.
And mu to d mu, if the
transmittance is 1,
this gives me 1/2 mu/ d mu.
So this is a really 1/4
if I want to get this.
2 times this gives me the
average transmittance weighted
over this sine theta vx1.
So this should give me 1/4.
This is gives me
the specific heat.
I forgot here, this is v1.
So what this one is
really all together,
I can write this
as 1/4 c times v
and times tau 1, 2
a different weight
average in terms of angle.
Here, I use a prime.
And there, I use a double prime.
So what I have then, this
one if I write together,
is delta T 1/4 cv and tau
1, 2 c1v1 on the first side
and 1, 2 transmittance.
Right so this is slightly
different than what
you have in chapter 5.
Chapter 5, we did the interface
thermobonded resistance.
And what I didn't have
is these two terms.
But later on, what
I discuss here,
there's a difference between
immediate temperature
and equilibrium temperature.
You go back to look
at the derivation.
And in that case, is
actually you come back,
and you add this to terms.
So there's a very
similarity, except to say
there is a little bit
different in the angle,
the weight itself.
Because there, we did not
consider this diffusion flux
distribution.
We did not consider f has this
tau weight division on flux.
So this is what I say
when I apply to interface,
I have a temperature heat
flux and temperature jump.
I derive a relation between flux
and temperature discontinuity
at the interface.
And for each problem, you
can apply similar strategy
to derive the type of
jump boundary condition.
And as I said for radiation,
there is one velocity.
And I'll show some
of the papers.
It's also interesting.
I remember after I
arrived at MIT once,
there was a professor, Professor
Probstein, Ronnie Probstein.
He came to my office, and
he brought me a paper.
He said, "take a
look at this paper.
I did a jump boundary
condition for photons."
And it turns out that his
paper was one year earlier then
in the field of
summer radiation,
we call [? Dessler ?]
boundary condition, photons.
So he actually derived
the same because he
was in fluid mechanics,
right if I guess.
He did the extension
to radiation.
So maybe it should be called the
Probstein boundary condition.
But in that field, it's
called [? Dessler ?]
What's the what's the
convenience with this?
So let's apply it.
I'm going to deal with now,
the heat conduction problem.
Let's say this is
a medium 1, 2, 3.
I have a thin film sandwiched
between two substrates,
two infinite substrates.
I have heat flow here.
And in each region, now because
I'm assuming the diffusion
approximation is valid,
so in each region,
I can use k2 dt/dx.
That's the diffusion.
But at the boundary now,
there is a discontinuity
at the interface.
And there is also not a
discontinuity at the interface.
So I can represent this
as three resistors--
the interface resistor,
the internal resistor,
and the second
interface resistor.
So let's say this is T1.
This is T1 prime.
Then this is T2 prime.
And this is the T2.
So because of the
interface, I have
the temperature discontinuity
between the two sides.
And inside the material,
because this is the two,
so I know q for heat conduction
along this direction.
I have q heat flow equals
k2 T1 prime minus T2 prime
divided by d.
I'm applying the diffusion
approximation right
to the boundary.
So that's my Fourier
law solution.
I have standard
thermal conductivity
times temperature difference
divided by the thickness.
And this is a flux, so
I didn't do the area.
And then say either
one, so I have q.
I have then T1 minus T1 prime.
If we look at this, this is a q.
T1 minus T1 prime,
that's the interface.
And then I have over 1 minus
tau 1,2 prime plus 2, 1 prime
over 2.
This is the averaging
over the angle.
And I have the c1v1 over 4,
tau 1,2 prime, double prime.
And in fact, it will be
easier if I do the other side
from 2 to 1 in this case.
Because here is my choice.
I read 1 to 2 in terms
of the property 1 to 2.
I said if you use the
reciprocity, the detail
balance, it's your
choice whether to choose
side one or side two.
And in this case, after
I wrote this down,
I said, it will be much
easier if I do c2v2,
because k2 is related to c2v2.
The thermal conductivity, k2
in the simplest form, we said
is c2v2 in the mean free path 2.
So it would be
easier if I do c2v2.
So this interface and
the third interface here,
the second interface,
2 to 3, I can similar
write q in terms of the
temperature T2 prime minus T2.
So at the end if I measure
the two temperature--
depends on where
you're measuring.
If I'm measuring the temperature
on the other side of these two
medium, and this you could do
your measurement for example,
a typical thermal interface
resistance measurement,
is people put a
very long material.
They do a thermocouple
either 1, 2, 3.
And they measure temperature,
and they extrapolate
to the interface because it's
hard to stick a thermocouple
exactly at the interface.
So in this case, that's your
extrapolated temperature.
On the same side, that's your
And then you just say OK, if I
use this temperature to define
the temperature
difference, I need
to eliminate the also,
T2 prime by similar,
the other interface.
And if I add all this
resistance together,
so you will get it effectively.
So at the end, if
you say my q equals
k effective thermal
conductivity or d, T1 minus T2.
I'm using the temperature
on these two sides.
I say what's the
interlayer effective with
thermal conductivity?
The enclosed the
conductivity conductance
inside the layer and the
two interface resistance,
I add this up together.
What I'll have is a k effective
thermal conductivity, kb.
The bulk is just k2 here.
K2 equals this.
If I take the ratio, what
I have is a 3d 4 gamma.
That's what you see here.
Gamma or d is the [? Lucien ?]
number for photon.
And 1 minus 1/2 tau 1, 2 prime
tau 2, 1 prime and tau 2,
2 prime, double prime
plus 1 minus again
1/2 tau 2, 3 prime, tau 3,
2 prime and tau 2, 3 prime
and plus 3d over 4 gamma.
So it's related to
interface transmitters,
and it's related to the
ratio of the thickness
over mean free path.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
Thank you.
So one thing that I can say that
this term is my addition there.
And I say this is a
interesting subtle point
is really, this
kind of addition,
make it very consistent
itself with the temperature
definition.
Because the temperature
in the Fourier
law is based on
isotropic distribution.
It goes in all directions.
And that immediate
temperature, when
we do, sometimes we say this is
incoming, this is the incoming.
Based on this
incoming temperature,
that's not consistent with
the Fourier law definition.
So one success of this addition
is you look at the limit
when there's no interface.
When there's no
interface, you should
get the Boltzmann connectivity.
And typically, so with
now interface, that means
the transmittance equals 1.
So this is 1, this is
1, this is 0, this is 0.
I go back to 1.
And most of the
other way, this term
is not included if you don't
do a consistent temperature
definition.
And this will be additional
artificial resistance.
So that's a success.
Anyway I think today, rather
than look at the literature,
I do want to just
show you a few papers.
In this case, I have to brag
a little bit about myself.
I wrote a few papers
I want to show--
hide the image, show image.
So when I was a
graduate student,
my advisor is a very wise man.
And he say, OK, the best
way to learn a subject
is to write a paper.
You want to work on subject?
Give you three months to
write the paper on it.
So that's the challenge
that I thought it's
a pretty good one, challenge.
And it turns out, so I wrote
a paper on this before.
So and now there is a boundary.
I say these are
boundary condition.
But the problem
is the temperature
is not in the photon.
That's of a photon transfer.
Photon transfer, you
measure a temperature
by sticking a thermocouple.
So that's a different
temperature definition.
So you have to be
very aware of how you
define how is the experiment.
So I use this strategy
I say apply basically,
this is what I just showed
here is you do your summation.
And you convert
into integration.
And it depends, you have
to define temperature.
If you do electron
transport, you
have to define your
chemical potential,
voltage or electrochemical
is the same.
Because these are all
thermodynamic quantities.
And so I took the same
strategy and applied
for both electrons or photons.
And again, you have to be aware
what exactly you're measuring.
In the case of
electron, for example,
you have metal
semiconductor interface.
You put the electrode
there, you will not
be measuring the voltage
exactly at the interface.
You're actually measuring over
the averaging of the metal.
So it turns out
that to do this, I
check a lot of papers in
electrical engineering.
People do thermionic
emission modeling.
And of course, some people, when
they do thermionic emission,
it's a layer inside the device.
And in that case, I see most
of the paper actually to me
is a wrong formula.
Because their formula
will not approach
the limit when there is no
barrier between the layer.
For electron transport,
it's the potential barrier
at the interface that
causes reflection.
So this is the Schottky
barrier situation
where you have a metal,
you have semiconductor.
There is this is a Fermi level.
And this is the electricity
from conduction band to vacuum.
At the interface, the
vacuum level is same.
So the difference of Fermi level
and the electrical affinity
give you the Schottky barrier.
And say you can have two
different semiconductor.
Also at the interface,
there's a barrier.
And I would challenge
you if you're interested
and go to read papers,
and electrical engineers
have done a lot of modeling.
And most of the time,
I just say this paper,
just stick in the
thermionic emission formula,
and into a device and combined
with diffusion equations
as well.
That's not consistent.
This is, hopefully
electrical engineer won't
be offended when I say this.
Because that's a reality--
check literature.
Next one-- so in fact, when I
originally wrote this paper,
I had the fluids there.
They slip flow for
velocity, rarefied gas.
I said, that's beautiful.
You do electron, you do
photon, you also do molecule.
And then I ask a student
of mine to check the paper.
So I wrote the paper.
I always try to write
the paper a year.
It doesn't always happen though.
So the student came back.
And he was very careful.
Chris Dempsey, he's a
professor at Berkeley.
He said, there's a
sign problem there.
I said, how could it be
there a sign problem?
I use the same strategy
apply to fluid.
And there it was
indeed, a sign problem.
So the fluid was not applicable.
And it took me a while, and
then we wrote another paper
to fix that sign problem.
And this was the velocity slip.
And this velocity
slip, what happens
is the difference for the flow
for this case is, it turns out
that you can use again--
so as I said, people did
the first order slip,
second order slip.
And to me that's always a math.
You do your expansion.
You say, distribution function,
I expand the first order.
And it didn't work.
Let me expand second order.
And I say that's just a
purely math-based, not a
physics-based argument.
And in fact for radiation,
this was really in the book.
You can check book.
There is expansion
of second order,
and the trend is
completely wrong.
It's really in the textbook.
So because my argument
is the Boltzmann equation
is a first order equation.
And then we expand
the second order,
you're creating
something strange.
So I say, OK, I'm
going to still use
the Boltzmann equation,
first order, solution
right to the boundary.
But what I'm missing in
the case of flow is say,
there is a pressure-driven term.
That's the source of the
[? Lucien ?] minimum emission
before.
So once I understand that
part, we add this back
into the boundary condition.
And here are some comparison.
So what do we have here?
This is velocity distribution
and normalized flow rate.
So this is considered
[INAUDIBLE],, I mentioned.
This is the Boltzmann
equation solution.
Here is the inverse
solution number.
So the universe is d
over mean free path.
So this is when d is a much
larger than the mean free path.
So that's a continuum.
You see this is the
first order correction.
So that's what Maxwell did it.
Maxwell did that
actually, this slip.
And then, it didn't work at
the [? Lucien ?] minimum is
a [? Lucien ?] number about 1.
So people expand
to second order.
You do have the
[? Lucien ?] minimum.
But this is a much
more over-predicting.
So we did this in sort
of in between one.
It's not perfect.
But at least I'm
in the right range.
So the point is this is you need
to understand the physics when
you do approximations.
And one more paper,
I want to mention.
So this is just a modified
boundary condition.
And then the one that
I said, let me go back
and modify the
Boltzmann equation.
The Boltzmann
equation, the headache
is phase space equation, so
you got to integrate equations.
And the Fourier of law
is a real space equation.
So you can solve,
find a difference,
all that much easier.
And also, I mentioned
before, I don't
believe this is a hyperbolic
equation because the hyperbolic
is the only time.
It doesn't take up
a space issue there.
So one strategy I
took is this split.
I say, well, this is Boltzmann
equation under relaxation
and time approximation.
And let me split the carrier
inside into two parts.
One part come from the boundary.
And when they go transport
inside, they're scattered.
There's a in scattering from
other direction or emission.
There's also outgoing scatter.
So what I did is
the boundary term
is just an outgoing scattering.
And that part, it's
purely from boundary.
So I can calculate analytically
based on the view factor
concept.
And then the other part is
this diffuse scattering.
So I can rewrite it
into a form that's
similar to the
continuing equation,
but that's only part of it.
So with that, I call this
ballistic diffusive equation.
So this is the
solution comparison.
This is a continuing equation.
The purpose of a
continuing equation
is to try to solve the
issue of the infinite speed
of the heat, diffusion.
A parabolic equation,
I said, that if you
have semi-infinite
media surface,
the temperature change, the
solution exponential decay
means the infinite way is not 0.
It's exponentially
small, but it's not 0.
That means it's
an infinite speed.
So the continuing equation
is a wave-type equation.
So there is a wavefront.
But the Boltzmann
equation, this is for a law
that supports my equation.
That's what the ballistic
diffusive equation.
It's closer.
It doesn't have this artificial
continuing-type solution.
So the story of
this is I was happy.
So I wrote up the paper.
And the night before
I submit, I said,
let me go to check
the radiation.
because I don't want to
make an outrageous claim
if other people worked on it.
And that's why I went
to check the radiation.
And I found, I'm not the
smartest guy in the world.
And people write down this.
Most of the time
when you do research,
you find out that the
people have done the--
so this was done for photon
by this guy, [INAUDIBLE]..
And in fact, the reason
in religion textbook,
I just teach you religion.
I didn't read that carefully.
But that's a steady state.
And this is a more general.
For photon, for heat conduction,
you care about trends in.
So a lot of things you can
do with the understanding
and intuition.
And the best way
to learn, like I
said, you write a paper on
it, you understand better.
Let me continue now.
So this is the chapter 7, which
is about the classical size
effects.
And now I'm moving
to the next chapter.
What I am going to talk is
the coupled energy conversion
and transport.
And then we say why,
if you see this book,
where is the energy conversion?
We say it's a nanoscale
energy conversion.
So let's start chapter 8.
So what this chapter
dealt with is really
when we think about the
energy conversion, of course,
we're familiar with
the steam turbine.
But microscopic is
really carrier energy
transform from one type of
carrier to another form,
from the photon to electron.
And in fact, let's
say you enjoy reading.
The electron raise the
temperature of photon.
That's the interaction
of the carrier.
That's the energy conversion.
So microscopically
is really, if I
think about a light
comes to an object.
The first step of
that energy conversion
is light is absorbed.
And that absorption either lift
the electron from valence band
to the conduction band--
that's what I want.
Or it excite a photon.
And in the case of
electricity, I don't like that.
So that's part of your
energy conversion.
Or when I have,
say, a conductor,
and I have electron flow
in the material conductor,
then what happens is
that the electrons
interact with the photon.
And again, say sometimes
you want to minimize that.
So you want the better
electric connectivity.
And eventually if you want
to get a useful workout,
it's a combination of this
excitation plus the transport,
where if you excite
electron whole pairs,
you say my photon is
energy energetic enough.
I will leave a hole behind
and get an electron here.
And the question is whether
you can extract out,
whether this electron
can go to your electrode.
If you go electrode, go
to external, you win.
Otherwise, the
nature of the one is
they are at a
higher energy state,
they won't go back since
it tends to be lazy,
minimum energy.
And this go back, will be
relaxed back to the bottom
and then relaxed
back to the bottom.
And now there is a gap.
And they can go relax through
the gap by emitting light
or by emitting photon.
Emitting light, if you use
laser, that's what you want.
But for photon, you
don't want that.
So this is really, when you
think about energy conversion,
is that how you can steer these
processes towards direction
that you would like to be.
And what I'm going
to do is to give you
a very brief introduction,
what's the mathematical tool
to do it.
It's still based on
Boltzmann equation.
But now let's look at
the interaction, focus
on the interaction term.
So if you recall, we talk about
briefly, the Fermi Golden rule.
What it say is that if
I have original system,
I have this
eigenstates that I got
from quantum
mechanical solutions.
And now I have a perturbation.
I have a photon comes
in, for example.
And that creates a perturbation
to the energy of the system.
A Hamiltonian, that's
a pretty big operation
on top of already,
the eigenstates.
So the Fermi Golden rule is
this is the initial stage,
this is the final stage,
that's the original solution,
allowable solution.
And then the Fermi
Golden rule tells me
the rate of that process
is 2 pi over H-bar.
And m, initial to
final scattering matrix
delta of the energy,
the final state energy
minus initial state energy.
That's what the
Fermi Golden rule.
And the scatter
matrix is related
to the wave function
of the final
and the initial states and
the perturbation Hamiltonian.
So we have the scatter matrix
equals the final state wave
function, the interaction
perturbation Hamiltonian,
and the initial state
wave function integrated
over the volume of
the interaction.
So what I want to
give is one example.
This kind of
scattering calculation
is extremely involved.
And say I want to use
one example to say people
have done a lot of work.
And if you want to look at it,
you should check literature.
And this is one example, let's
look at the electron photon
scattering.
So if you think
about how electrons
will go through
semiconductor, how
electrons get
scattered by photons.
And any process, you have to--
I think I made those
comments before physics
and even reciprocal space.
But also, you have to go
think about the real event.
If you have a real world
picture, real space
picture of what's
happening, then you
can describe that in terms
of the reciprocal space
is just math, mathematics.
And if I think about electron,
my picture before is--
if you think about
crowning a penny model,
I have periodical potential.
That solution will give
me a bandgap, for example.
And of course, when I did with
the photon, I have a spring.
So the bandgap for this let's
say, one-dimensional lattice,
depends on, of course,
the lattice constant
and depends on the
potential profile.
Now what photon does is
when your lattices vibrate,
the lattice constant
is changing.
The lattice constant change,
you could say this fluctuation,
visually you can
think about if my band
gap depends on lattice constant,
lattice consonant is vibrating.
So the electron bandgap
is changing there
due to the lattice vibration.
And that created
the perturbation
for the electron energy
level and created
a scatter of the electron.
So let's try this problem.
And so the perturbation
to the Hamiltonian--
and in the 1D,
let's say electron
is close to the bandgap is
a function of the lattice
constant and the displacement
of each lattice point.
So this gives you
a delta a the mass
of the initial steady state.
So this is the in the 1D.
If I do a 3D situation,
I can do an expansion.
So if I do Taylor expansion,
it's dEc/da du/dx x times a.
So in 3D, this can be written
as equals Za and the divergence
of the atomic
displacement vector, u.
And this Za is the called
the deformation potential.
Za is how the bandgap check
the conduction band will change
as a function of the volume
change of the crystal,
so if you squeeze the crystal,
how the bandgap would change.
So this Za is called
deformation potential.
And now I'm going to use this
perturbed Hamiltonian back
into the Fermi
Golden rule and try
to say what is this
scatter matrix from i to f.
So this is the math part.
And the way to do
it is you say you
are going to integrate over the
volume, your initial function
and your final wave function.
And those are the wave functions
of the electron because I'm
looking at the electron gets
scattered by lattice vibration.
So the lattice vibration is
perturbed, the Hamiltonian
of the electron.
So physically,
what we have is you
can have a electron at a certain
wave vector energy come in
and interact with
a lattice wave.
And let's say at a certain wave
vector and a certain frequency.
And this can be combined.
The energy of the photon
is given to the electron.
So you gather the momentum,
energy, new momentum,
new energy for electron.
This is the inelastic process.
The photon disappear.
You could also have
the process where
electron with a certain
energy, momentum
is split it into another
electron at a different energy
momentum with a photon,
create a photon.
So that's the
interaction process.
And mathematically
what it will say
is I want to plug this
into the scatter matrix.
But the wave function, if
I know the wave vector,
I can use the prime
wave representation.
The wave function is a
proportional exponential, i, k,
r.
You have an energy
frequency also in there.
But the energy part
is actually taken
care of by this delta function
in the Fermi Golden rule.
You could keep, that
everything together.
You'll see the latter coming
out of this delta function.
If I look at the displacement
of the atom, the displacement
of the atom, again, now you
can go say this is each space,
each point in the crystal could
have a different displacement.
But we did a Fourier
transform before.
Any function, you can express
in terms of sine, and cosine.
That's the Fourier series.
This is the reciprocal
lattice representation.
So we can say different
wave vector of the u, q,
and exponential mass, i.
We've got t minus q dot r.
Eventually this omega t will
be merged into the energy,
into part of the
energy conservation.
But I wrote it down
here because to say,
when we think about the energy
of the lattice vibration,
we need to say 1/2 mv square.
That time derivative
will give me omega.
Now if I go to plug in
these two wave functions
into the scatter matrix,
the scatter matrix from k
to k prime, this is the electron
scattering matrix with vector.
That means say I have one is a
k, the either initial or final.
The other is a k-prime
initial or final.
And what I have then is this one
could be written as Za over v.
And because I'm substituting
in the Za, the Hamiltonian,
and then I have when
I substitute the u,
this H-prime into
the expression,
I will have a qu q times the
uq and exponential mass i
k-prime plus q minus k times r.
You see here, I didn't carry
that mass, only the t term,
just looking at this
special term here.
So the point I want
to make is here
if you look at this expression,
what really scatter photon?
Uq, so for photon,
this is the plane wave.
This is a photon with vector,
as a wave vector direction,
photon wave
propagation direction.
This is the lattice
displacement direction.
Whether it's a transverse wave,
if it's a perpendicular to q,
or it's a longitudinal
wave, if it's
in the same direction of q.
Because of this deformation
potential, at the end
my scatter matrix is the
dot product of q times u.
It immediately tells you
that transverse photon here
do not scatter electrons,
because this is 0.
And it's a longitudinal photon
that will scatter electrons.
That's one.
Secondly, if we look at
this integration, plane wave
integration, this will be
rapidly sine cosine function
average over the volume.
Because this is exponential.
And it's a complex function,
is either sine and cosine.
If you average sine and
cosine over a large number,
you know it's 0.
So unless those exponents is 0,
the rest of this is always 0.
So what you have here,
essentially with this mass,
you gather the
momentum conservation.
Because when this one is 0
it's 2 pi of reciprocal lattice
factor, you get this one
will not be a 0 function.
So what you have is a
delta k-prime plus q
because I have this and the k.
So what it means is that,
k-prime plus q minus k
equals 0.
That's the momentum
conservation.
Hk is the electron momentum.
Hq is the photon momentum.
So it came from laterally,
from this integration.
And in fact, if this
one is rather not
0, is equal to g-- g is
reciprocal lattice factor,
we talked before.
And that's still fine.
You integrate that.
It will not be 0 because
you got a 2 pi, i 2 pi.
And but say, for electron
photon, this seldom happens.
It's typically a
Patagonian semiconductor.
Because the semiconductor
is a conduction band.
And most of the electron
is at this location.
So it doesn't need to--
with g, it's the
reciprocal lattice vector,
pi over a, that's a very
large momentum there.
So that the rate of that
process don't happen often.
It's a typical normal process.
So essentially, you can
also relate the qu velocity,
the amplitude of all
the lattice displacement
to how many photon you have.
Because this is all
related to energy.
One is the photon picture.
Displacement is the
actual moment there.
So if you think
about the energy,
because I want to relate
this to temperature.
So energy conservation, what
we have is 1/2 mv squared.
This is the kinetic energy.
Plus potential energy,
1/2 kx squared,
that's equal to the total
energy of the photons.
So if I do that, what I'll
have is 1/2 half of v,
omega squared and
the uq squared.
So this is a kinetic
plus potential energy
equals h-bar omega nq.
Nq is the number of
photons at that temperature
with this momentum.
At equilibrium, that's
the Boltzmann state,
no, the Bose-Einstein
statistics.
So this one, nq, is a
function of temperature omega
at equilibrium.
So the reason I do
this is so that I
can write the final
expression in terms
of different temperature,
what's the electron-photon
interaction?
I convert this
displacement factor
in terms of the
number of photons.
So if you do this, you go
to say essentially, write
the scattering term, df/dt.
And this term, let's say
let's look at this first one.
We look at the this term.
So from k-prime absorb a
photon, and in lation process,
go to another electron.
And for this process, when we
sum up, this is the transfer,
this is a 1.
From k to k-prime
or k-prime to k,
you can write different
states, slight different forms.
So what I have here is
this is the sum of all q
and 2 pi h-bar in the
front and the q squared,
and the h Za squared and
2 rho v omega and the nq.
So this is the scatter matrix.
Fermi Golden rule, I'm
applying Fermi Golden rule,
2 pi h square.
And then now when
I scatter, I say,
from how many electrons I
have, either the k-prime--
because this will go
in from k-prime to k.
So that's the Fermi
Dirac statistics I have,
how many electrons I
have at this k-prime.
But then when I
scatter into k, I
have to see how many
states are empty.
This is the Pauli
exclusion principle.
So this is a k.
Then I have with
this delta function,
k-prime q to k, that's a result
out of my scatter matrix.
And then I have my
energy conservation,
another delta for E--
this is the final energy--
equals the sum of
E-prime plus h omega.
So that's the
Very complex, but people
actually did this.
And if you go the
read papers there,
sometimes people still do it.
electron photon scattering
is very difficult. And this is
one of the four possibilities.
So you actually have
four terms like this.
This term we talked
about is from k-prime
to k by absorber photon.
I can have from k-prime
to k to emitter photon.
Both of this processes
increase the number
of electrons in the k state.
I can have a reverse.
The k is scattering out to
k-prime by absorber and emitter
photon.
So there are four
process that give you
the lap balance for the gain
in the Boltzmann equation, that
scattering term.
We talked before in terms of
two-particle collision model.
Now I'm doing electron-photon
collision model.
And the point is that
you see at the end
that you gather
all those products.
That's temperature-dependent.
And when you want to solve
with the Boltzmann equation
to solve for this distribution,
it's pretty tedious.
But the people who have
done a lot of work on this,
say Shockley.
Shockley is the inventor
of the transistor.
You look at the papers,
they study all those.
And there are other people, like
Conway, say very solid work.
And so when you put this
into Boltzmann equation,
like I said, this is the only
one of the four processes.
There are four terms.
And in the 60s, people
don't do computers.
So this is all
done analytically.
So I actually repeated
the derivation.
If you read the book, I did it.
I remember when I did the
electron-photon scattering
and I had a factor
I couldn't reconcile
what's the difference.
So I have a factor of
pi or pi 1/3 difference
from the derivation.
So I put my result there.
I couldn't find where
it was different.
So now what happens,
is if you say,
these are all the
scattering term.
So I say, the anytime you
have carrying interaction,
you can do this.
If you want to calculate
what's the photon absorption,
your photon comes in
at a perturbation.
And it was excited
electron holes.
And you have to look
at whether there's
empty states for the
electron to actually
be lifted from here to here.
So those are all
the scattering terms
you can right into
the right-hand side
for each process, the
Boltzmann equation.
And at they end, let's go back
to the Boltzmann equation,
df/dt plus v dot rf f
over m, so this give me a.
So I will have to put af.
And this is the scattering term.
We say for each
process, you can write
all those different
summation integers.
And you can solve it.
And my last point is that
in the previous chapter,
we use relaxation time.
We couldn't deal with.
We just say, this is it.
So What we did before, is
this is a minus f0 over tau.
But I say, that's a little bit
cheating, a lot of cheating.
It's a huge integer you write
in the very simple form.
And you see if you read the
book, an electrical engineer,
very often what people
do is the f of course,
even term plus the odd term.
And you substitute this back
into the scatter integer,
those expressions.
And you find out that a df/dt,
roughly this scattering term
to actually write into
that's due to the even term
and due to the odd therm.
And turns out, the odd
term could be roughly
write into relaxation time.
The even term cannot.
What the human term represents
is the inelastic scattering.
Electrons fall out.
When they scatter,
they lose energy.
And so they have energy change.
And for those kind of
things, you cannot.
And in fact, you go
do this expression,
you say it's roughly
is Te minus Tp.
It's the effective
temperature difference
between electron-photon
times this electron-photon
scattering, the energy
coupling coefficient.
So for inelastic scattering,
rigorous speaking,
the relaxation
time is not valid.
So we've done a lot of what
I said, this approximation we
did before.
We saw Boltzmann equation.
It was really just
using those terms.
But I say when there is a
difference between electron
and photon temperature,
if you pass
a current through
a material, and you
do some of those
coefficient, you plug it in,
and you find out that
in normal conditions,
the difference between
electron and photon temperature
difference is very small.
So this term still, is not that
important in normal conditions.
But it becomes very important
if you have transient terms.
Like you have a laser--
for example, we do
experiment, the pump pro,
I shoot the laser on the metal.
And I can observe
very hot electrons.
And so electron can be much
harder than photon temperature.
Or if you have a MOSFET, say you
have MOSFET, you have a source,
you have a drain
term, you have a gate.
And it turns out that
electrons gain energy
when you apply voltage.
And on the drain side, they
can be 1,000 times degrees,
much hotter than the lattice.
And so for those
kind of cases, you
need to become more careful.
And I will talk more
along those lines.